how are you i'm good i'm really good how
are you doing
i'm good where are you right now
i'm in my house um i'm i'm still kind of
quarantining
in my home doing homeschool and trying
to
work and be a single mom all at once oh
my god that's
right i don't know anything i don't know
any basic math beyond say third grade
level
i honestly couldn't help my kids so i
give it i give it up for you
because that's tough to be a single
parent right now during
kovid to be tough yeah you should have
seen me this morning trying to zoom call
uh and work while he was supposed to be
doing school
and i'm having a serious conversation he
comes up behind me he puts a fireman hat
on me
and i just i just looked at my meeting
and shrugged and you know at least
everyone's very compassionate with each
other right now so i think it's
it's fine but yeah it's it's pretty wild
it's pretty wild
well it sounds like you handled it well
in the 1970s when i was
a young man that age when we did stuff
like that to our parents
they lost it on us they scr you know
that's that's what happened that's what
used to happen in the good old days
yeah you just get a backhand like
[Laughter]
there was no physical hitting but there
was good emotional scarring emotional
scarring